This is the payroll recording for the pay period of November 24th to November 30th.
This is the Monday AM shift and this is all before tip-out so we need to calculate it.
Austin Kelly before tip-out $266.23 and then his tip-out was and this needs to go to Ryan Alexander.
Ryan was the utility guy so Austin Kelly's tip-out was $46.30.
Again that $46.30 needs to go to Ryan.
Then the other server was Brooke Neal and this is before tip-out $192.19 total tips and fees.
Her portion of the tip-share again going to Ryan Alexander is $34.50.
Again we need to do those calculations.
Okay now the Monday PM shift and these are all going to be before tip-out numbers so we need to do this calculation to find out the tip-out.
Servers Austin Kelly before tip-out made $469.17 his tip-out was $81.95.
Kevin Worley before tip-out made $142.62 and he needs to tip-out $16.30.
Mike Walton before tip-out made $255.28 and his tip-out is $46.75.
That tip-out for the Monday PM shift all needs to go to Ryan Alexander who was our utility guy.
Now on to Tuesday November 25th 2025 this is the AM shift and these are before tip-out numbers.
Brooke Neal before tip-out $159.17 she needs to tip-out $27.15.
Austin Kelly before tip-out $156.66 and he needs to tip-out $32.88.
Both of their tip-outs need to go to Ryan Alexander who was the utility guy.
Now on to the Tuesday November 25th 2025 PM shift these are all before tip-out numbers as well.
Austin Kelly before tip-out made $373.83 his tip-out was $21.99.
Janelle Bakke before tip-out $306.17 her tip-out is $35.68.
Mark Baryanek before tip-out $289.84 his tip-out needs to be $36.80 and all of those three tip-outs combined go to our utility guy that night and that was Ryan Alexander.
Okay on to the Wednesday November 26th 2025 AM shift these are before tip-out numbers so we need to do the calculation just like with all the other ones this week so far.
Austin Kelly before tip-out $258.85 his tip-out needs to be $48.60.
Brooke Neal before tip-out $276.57 she needs to tip-out $37.80 and both of those tip-outs need to go to our utility guy Ryan Alexander.
Now on to Wednesday November 26th PM shift again these are before tip-out numbers Janelle Bakke $377.86 she needs to tip-out $61.80.
Brooke Neal before tip-out $158.54 she needs to tip-out $22.55 Austin Kelly before tip-out $436.29 his total tip-out is $74.85.
All those tip-outs need to go to Ryan Alexander who was our utility guy.
Now on to Friday November 28th 2025 we're skipping Thursday because that was Thanksgiving so don't worry about Thursday.
These are going to be before tip-out numbers.
Austin Kelly $432.89 he needs to tip-out $75.49.
Kevin Worley before tip-out $426.66 he needs to tip-out $55.45 and those tip-outs need to go to our utility guy Ryan Alexander.
Okay again this is the Friday November 28th 2025 AM shift these are their before tip-out numbers.
Austin Kelly $432.89 he needs to tip-out $75.49.
Kevin Worley $426.66 he needs to tip-out $55.45.
The utility guy was Ryan Alexander so those tip-outs both need to go to him.
Okay now the Friday November 28th PM shift these are the final numbers.
So this is exactly what needs to go on the final tip report.
Kevin Worley $147.51 Mike Walton $147.51 Janelle Bakke $147.51
Ryan Alexander $10.72 Atticus Euseglio $36.55
On to the Saturday November 29th 2025 AM shift these are the final numbers.
So it's already calculated this is what needs to go on the final tip thing.
Kevin Worley $136.60 Mark Buryanek $136.60 Atticus $30.80
Ryan $28.62
Okay and this is the PM shift again these are the final numbers so this is all after tip-out.
Kevin Worley $247.28 Mark Buryanek $247.28
Ryan Alexander was the utility guy and he needs to make $76.19
Now Sunday November 30th 2025 again these are the final numbers.
Kevin Worley $111.12 Mike Walton $111.12
Ryan Alexander was our utility guy he needs to make $34.72
Now the PM shift these are the final numbers $16.80 to Kevin Worley $16.80 to Mike Walton
$7.35 to our utility guy Ryan Alexander
And now cook tips
Slade Walker $62.06
Tori Wells $12.62
Warren Lewis $64.17
That's the whole payroll.